- [Lauren] Hi, I'm
Lauren from Khan Academy,
and today I'm going to
give you an overview
of how to set up accounts for yourself
and your children on Khan Academy.
We'll also go over how you
can find relevant content
for your kids and view their progress.
This video is meant for parents
with kids who are 13 or older.
If your child is 12 or younger,
please see our other video
called Parent Quick-Start Tips
for Kids Ages 12 and Under.
We recommend that you
and your child go through
the account creation steps together
and collaborate to come up with a plan
for learning on Khan Academy.
To begin, go to www.khanacademy.org
and have your child click Sign
up in the upper right corner.
On the sign up page,
have your child enter their date of birth,
and sign up via Google or Facebook.
Or create a username and
password and sign up with email.
Next, your child can
select their grade level
and click Continue.
On the next page, you'll see
courses that we recommend
for your child based on their grade level.
Have them choose one or
more and click Continue.
You can also use the See all
link to view the full menu,
in case your child would
like to select other topics
that interest them.
Now, your child is ready to go.
They can click the blue
Start button for any course
to start with the very first lesson,
or click the See all link
to browse the entire course.
If your child is not sure
where to start, here's a tip,
most Khan Academy math courses
include a course challenge
that can help you quickly
find where your child
needs practice and where
they're already good to go.
To get there, scroll to the
bottom of the course page,
and click Start Course challenge.
These usually take 30 to 45 minutes,
and will give you some good clues
about where to direct their learning.
You can also suggest to
your child that they start
one grade level below their current grade,
or even start at kindergarten
and work their way up.
If you would like to track
your child's progress,
you can create a parent account.
Go to www.khanacademy.org
and click Sign up
in the upper right corner.
On the sign up page, select Parent.
Now, you can sign up
with Google, Facebook,
or you can sign up with email,
and create a username and password.
Once you sign up, you'll be
taken to your parent dashboard.
Click Add a child.
Then, click the My child
already has an account link.
Enter your child's email
address and click Next.
Your child will receive
an email with a link
to confirm the connection to your account.
Once your child activates via the link,
refresh your parent dashboard,
and click your child's username.
This takes you to the progress report
where you can keep track
of what they're learning
and how much time they're spending.
Your child can also see this
report through their account
by clicking Progress
in the left navigation.
Thanks for watching, and
we hope you and your child
enjoy learning on Khan Academy.